crazy do you believe that science is The
Cutting Edge
it is
the modus operandi for uh humans to
understand and see the universe and that
it was the great development I mean I
can go back to
definitely the Greeks the pre-greeks
through the whole uh period of the
Renaissance and in particular there is
that period that is called The Age of
Reason
we have now entered into the age of
unreason in the world around us although
everything is trying to
unify with
everybody communicating with information
uh and the information flood is kind of
overwhelming and it does split into
streams and we see this manifested all
around us but what should be at the core
is the basic quest for knowledge which
is the Quest for science so science is
then transcending just physics or
chemistry or biology it is at the heart
of uh humanity and what how people
should be operating those to say you
want knowledge and you want to apply
knowledge to the world around us what's
meant by the term universe
well that's an interesting question
because what is often put out there is
the word which I am not that fond of
although many of my friends like to use
it the Multiverse
there is only universe that's what the
uni is in front it's the one and then
the question is how complex is it but it
is all that there is basically by
definition the thing that is very
humbling if you like the universe seems
vast the one the part that we can see
but the way we think of it now is that
what we see is only a tiny part of a
much much greater whole then the
question is is it all connected or are
there disconnected elements well if it
is a completely disconnected element we
could never know about it because
there's no communication the things that
are beyond the speed of light reach we
don't get information on the only way we
can get that information
is by looking
around us in the universe
try understand how the patterns have
developed and then say I'll go back to
one two three Infinity you then say that
this applies to the region that you
cannot see that of course uh is
impossible to get right really
but on the other hand
um it is clear that the themes that we
see around us and hope to the
observable edge of the universe there is
a commonality I mean that is an amazing
thing right that you know you don't go
into some area of the universe which is
drastically different I mean it in time
it's different because it evolves but
it isn't like uh at least in the patch
that we can see that there is a
coherence
the coherence is essential basically but
for me I don't really see why there
should be coherence
I mean coherence writ really large that
is to say everything connected
in fact one of the things that I'm
known for is uh of label the cosmic web
which of course web means something to
everybody because of the um internet web
but uh what that word caught or those
words Cosmic web indicate is the
interconnectivity of everything and that
every aspect of the universe is
connected with every answer that's sort
of cliche and obvious but it's also
incredibly profound it means that
everything is dressed in the
interactions with everything else and uh
in particular it's writ large
in the universe that we can see uh but
for me
the universe is beyond that and uh one
way you can think about this is
um
I don't want to get into the
concept of a universal simulation
although that's an interesting point but
uh
in a sense we think of the universe as a
realization of reality
and then
we think there can be a lot of realities
and at some level quantum mechanics
has those uh
realities interacting with each other
because uh
the quantum theory
uh is one of its basic elements is that
information diffuses which means that
you don't you cannot over concentrate
information so it flows out I mean
that's a manifestation of that is things
like the hydrogen atom Etc where you
don't have the electric charge right at
the center on top of the proton the
uncertainty aspects of the universe
enforce
through this kind of interaction that
it's got you know a ground state I'm
maybe going too far here but it's got a
ground state structure and uh you know
that's manifested everywhere that there
are these structures that occur and one
aspect of the structure is uh uh
information trying to propagate from
whatever the origin is to
uh throughout the Universe I mean that's
sort of one of the main themes that I
work on in in what I do research on that
was a long way from what is universe but
in fact it isn't because it's in my view
at the heart of universe you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy